[Music]
hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
and
i have a lot of dead skin it's gotten a
lot worse during lockdown because
normally i keep my skin quite exfoliated
for pull but dance studios are closed so
i've just been letting myself turn into
a scaly snake just sort of growing a
cocoon around myself so when i found out
about these special exfoliating mitts
that make rolls of skin come off i got
pretty excited because i knew i was in
for a treat a disgusting treat i was
actually contacted by a journalist at
insider who wanted to do a story about
these exfoliating myths well we normally
have 10 to 20 layers of dead skin in our
stratum corneum this is the topmost
level of our epidermis these cells
normally shed in a process called
declamation but sometimes your skin
needs a bit of a nudge how well your
skin describes depends on a lot of
factors like age hydration the climate
you're in your skin care routine in
general moisturized skin sheds more
easily if you have too much dead skin
then it looks dry and flaky and dull
and it can also trap ingrown hairs these
mitts are sold as turkish bath mirrors
but i think they're actually used by a
lot of cultures around the middle east
and north africa they're traditionally
used after a steam bath when the skin is
really soft they're mostly advertised
for use on the body but some of them
also say that you can use them on your
face the most famous one is probably the
baiden glove biden glove it is 72
it has rave reviews it calls itself the
superior exfoliating glove and the
keywords on amazon include
dead skin highly recommend make sure
stretch marks dry skin worth every every
penny worth the money much dead so
overall very promising but right next to
it on amazon i also saw gloves that were
only eight dollars each so of course i
had to buy them all and try them out
there are actually two types of the
cheaper gloves there's one that is a lot
rougher and one that is a lot softer and
the listings didn't really give an
indication about how rough or soft they
were going to be the myths are made from
rayon fiber they have a weave that makes
them a balance of rough and soft so
rough enough to scrub off skin but soft
enough that you don't destroy your skin
they work a bit like really fine grit
sandpaper they mechanically buff away
dead skin cells so these are our three
contenders for
great mitt i guess
this is the baden mitten this is the
expensive one it comes in
i guess relatively fancy cardboard
packaging it's like a sachet that's
covered in
very direct marketing like
shopping tv style packaging
it has like a little
money back guarantee
seal in the corner it has papyrus font
is that how you say it i don't know
probably should have checked
it also comes with like the story of the
mitten inside it and like
it's got you know actual marketing copy
with instructions
in theory this is meant to last for two
years
now with the other two mittens obviously
they don't come in anywhere near as
interesting packaging they came in like
a sandwich bag
but i don't know i don't think i'd pay
all that extra money just for the
cardboard packaging although it is
probably a nice read so that's your
choice
with the texture
the expensive bait and mission it has a
fine sort of grit but it still feels
rough
with this one it has the same fine
fineness of grit but it feels a lot
smoother almost like it's been worn down
already
and with the third mitt it's a lot
rougher and a lot coarser as well so
we'll see how these go
in terms of results after using them a
bunch of times you can actually really
feel the difference between the fabric
the bait and glove feels a lot finer and
thinner these other two gloves are a bit
stiffer they don't feel like they're
quite as nicely woven i guess the bait
and glove definitely feels like it's
higher quality so the instructions say
to try these right after a shower and to
rub back and forth and not in circles i
tried out the baiden glove versus the
red glove on my shins the bait and glove
definitely gets the rolls off much
faster you can see there's a lot more
rolls but the red glove does pretty well
as well the black glove is a bit
underwhelming compared to the other two
you can see there are some rolls but it
takes a lot of effort so with all the
messing around with the cameras i think
my second shin dried out a bit before i
got to it so it might be a bit biased so
i tried again on my thighs but i did it
with the red and the black gloves first
so i tried the opposite order with the
cheaper gloves first with the black
glove i got a tiny bit with the red mint
i got some rolls and with the butter
mitt i got some rolls as well so i think
the red mitt is capable of getting these
rolls maybe not as much as the bait and
mitt my skin was super super soft
afterwards now all of these mitts say
you can use them on your face
but i'm really hesitant to use the red
one on my face because it feels so much
rougher than the other two
the beta mitt apparently is fine for
your face and i did end up using it on
one of my cheeks i did get some small
rolls off but i didn't press very hard
because i was pretty scared
and my cheek felt redder and hotter
afterwards but
it didn't really sting any more than my
other cheek when i put on products
afterwards so i don't know if i would
recommend using it on your face maybe if
you don't use any other exfoliating
products if you don't use any irritating
ingredients then using this maybe once a
week on your face with very gentle
pressure is fine but i think for most of
us people who use a lot of irritating
skin care products it's probably not the
best thing your barrier is probably
compromised enough already i also looked
at the weave of these under a microscope
so you can see that the beta mid does
have a different weave from the other
two and that might explain why it works
a bit better i also looked through the
roll cover glove through my microscope
you can see that the rolls are actually
dead skin yes this is what it looks like
if you put your eyeball right up to it
the mitt is intact the rolls don't look
like the fibers in the mid so it's very
different from a peeling gel where the
rolls are bunched up product now about
the claims the beta myth does claim to
be like microdermabrasion and i think
that might be a bit much i really don't
think this is going to do as much as
microdermabrasion
maybe if they had a study where they
compared the two head to head i'd be
okay with that comparison but as it
stands i think it is
pretty exaggerated so it says there's an
immediate improvement in blackheads and
large pores i think with black as maybe
you might dislodge them especially after
the steam from the shower but i don't
think you'll do that much blackheads are
oxidized sebum and cells inside your
pores they're not really on the surface
this sort of exfoliation is very surface
level i think you would get much more
benefit if you use something like a
chemical exfoliant that can get deeper
into the pores same with large pores i
don't think it's going to do very much
with firmness and wrinkles i think this
does increase the circulation which can
make your skin temporarily more firm
it's not going to do anything like
stimulate collagen for example though
now with wrinkles i think exfoliation in
general does help the appearance of
wrinkles and that's simply because if
you have a whole bunch of dead skin it
can make wrinkles look a lot coarser
scars stretch marks skin tone and
dryness i mean it might make them look a
bit better because you're helping the
surface look better but it's not going
to have a really big effect now scars
and stretch marks
massage in general can reduce stretch
masks and it can soften up scars
but
beyond that i don't think the glove is
doing anything special exfoliation can
also make them look better but again
it's not some sort of magical property
of the glove skin tone exfoliating can
get rid of maybe some cells on the
surface but i don't think it's going to
make a massive difference not like the
difference that a proper active like
lactic acid could it can definitely help
remove dry flaky skin detox that's
always a red flag for pseudoscience
discolorations that's really vague even
tanning will definitely work fake tan
reacts with dead skin so if you have a
lot of dead skin in one area and not
somewhere else you end up with a patchy
tan and so exfoliating before a tan is
always a good idea acne control i guess
all exfoliation can help a bit with acne
but
that is a pretty big claim for something
that's just a physical exfoliant so are
these gloves too rough on your skin
well i think it really depends one of
the issues with these is that it is
really prone to user error it's very
exciting to be rubbing off all of this
dead skin but it turns out that you need
dead skin those 10 to 20 layers on the
surface of your skin are there to
protect the living layers of your skin
so if you get rid of too many then you
end up with a really compromised barrier
you end up with stinging and irritation
and it takes a while to build that
barrier back up so you need to practice
a bit of self-control with these you
can't go too hard you can't use them too
often i think it's especially dangerous
on your face because a lot of us already
use active ingredients that can pack
down our stratum corneum they're already
exfoliating for example and so if you're
using this on top of all those
exfoliants then you're probably getting
rid of too much skin that means that you
end up with a compromised barrier and
that means irritation sensitivity your
face skin is also thinner and so you've
got less to take off to start with so
after i tried this mid out on my face on
this half only i noticed there was a
patch of skin here that was a bit dry
and flaky and it also stung a bit when i
put sunscreen on it for about a week
afterwards i thought i used it pretty
gently just hard enough to get some
rolls so yeah over exfoliating is really
easy with these mitts i wouldn't
recommend using it on your face if you
use any other exfoliating actors maybe
any other irritating actors which i
think is probably everyone who is deep
enough down the skincare rabbit hole to
be watching my channel so for face
exfoliation i would probably recommend
something different such as a chemical
exfoliant or maybe a scrub
probably not these definitely not the
rougher ones you also have to be careful
when looking after these you want to let
these dry out properly in between uses
the reason is after you've rubbed off
all of this dead skin
dead skin is really good food for
bacteria and when you have moisture and
dead skin they grow and so you end up
with lots of bacteria on these then you
rub them back onto your skin into your
skin and you end up with a bacterial
infection the most common one is
pseudomonas folliculitis this is when
the bacteria end up in your hair
follicles and it looks a little bit like
tiny red pimples with pus in them that
is bacteria not the kind of gross we
want so is the 70 brand name version
worth it i think it does have a much
nicer texture than the cheaper ones it
feels a lot more effective without being
too rough it also feels a lot better
constructed so it should last a bit
longer it says it'll last up to two
years according to the packet but i
think the cheaper ones can definitely
still do the job but it might take a few
goes to find the right one you might end
up with one that doesn't really do much
you might end up with one that is a bit
too rough and you'll have to use it a
lot more gently i think if i wasn't
doing this for a video i would probably
just buy five cheaper ones and see which
one worked best so i hope you like this
slightly disgusting video you can follow
me on instagram at lab muffin beauty
science and check out my blog for more
about the science behind beauty products
see you next time to nerd out more and i
will try not to talk about disgusting
dead skin